it's very wonderful to be here today I'm
not normally in Los Angeles but this is
very timely and I'm really honored to
speak with you today it's a wonderful
occasion and I'm very very grateful to
have this opportunity as I say to talk
with you this afternoon most of you know
me as a singer songwriter musician
person but quite a few years ago my life
took a very purposeful turn towards a
different direction and if you'll
indulge me for a few minutes I'd like to
share with you how the shift came about
in November of 2003 I was invited to
take part in a special concert held in
Cape Town South Africa for the launch of
Nelson Mandela's HIV AIDS Foundation for
double 664 some of you may be aware of
Mandela's foundation on the day before
the event all the featured artists were
asked to join with Mandela at the main
exercise yard on Robben Island prison
where he was scheduled to address a
gathering of international press and
photographers standing in front of his
former prison cell he spoke about the
hiv/aids pandemic as it was affecting
the entire nation of South Africa a
country with the highest rates of an HIV
infection in the world
Mandela described a situation as a
virtual genocide with thousands of lives
being wiped out on a daily basis to add
to this he emphasized that women were
the most vulnerable frontline victims a
fact which to this day seems to be
almost invisible in terms of global
media coverage and profile as a woman
and mother myself this invisibility
stuck
Killingly disturbing chord with me it
was still is profoundly distressing to
know that the world at large didn't seem
to be aware particularly care about the
scale of the appalling tragedy that was
taking place in terms of girls and
women's health a generation of mothers
were dying leaving helpless and
vulnerable young children to be raised
by grandmothers are taken in by
orphanages or in the worst case scenario
to simply fend for themselves women are
after all the carers the nurturers and
very often the sole pillars of
grassroots communities and broader
societies women are after all half the
world as the book so aptly entitled
Mandela's message deeply troubled me and
I resolved to make a contribution
towards making a difference from that
moment on subsequently in the years to
follow
I bore witness to the ravages of AIDS on
visits to hospitals clinics orphanages
women's support groups and rape crisis
centers I started to realize that girls
and women living in poverty in so-called
developing countries and in this country
to bear the heaviest burdens with the
fewest resources having to deal with
unspeakable hardships lack of protection
support or opportunities at every aspect
of their lives it all adds up to the
most cruelly continuous global human
rights injustice to illustrate let me
share some facts
around the world one in three women will
experience physical or sexual violence
in their lifetime one in three six
hundred and three million women live in
countries where domestic violence is not
considered a crime out of the seven
hundred and fifty seven million adults
who cannot read or write guess what two
thirds are women every minute of the day
one girl aged 15 to 24 contracts HIV in
African countries hiv/aids is the cause
of the highest mortality rates among
women of reproductive age think about it
women and girls account for seventy-two
percent of human trafficking victims
thirty-nine thousand girls become child
brides every day while rape and sexual
violence continues to be used as a
weapon of war in countries around the
world now I know that many of you here
are bound to be aware much of this I'm
quoting the facts to illustrate the
level and scale of existing disparity
around the globe and as I read them it
never fails to shock me every time
living in Western countries we can often
take the rights and resources we have
easily accessed throughout our lives for
granted which is not our fault but we
just don't know just results in a kind
of easy complacency we still need to
remember with gratitude that over a
hundred years ago it took tremendous
collective sacrifice to earn the right
to vote
thanks for the fearless dedication of
the women of the suffragette movement
and while we have a tremendous spotlight
right now on women's rights through
hashtag me too time's up and the women's
movement the focus is mostly on the
rights of women in Western countries
without including the enormous gap that
exists for girls and women of the global
south now the term feminist has only
recently be really embraced again back
into the zeitgeist would you agree
applause for feminism there's a new
generation of young women prepared to
identify with what feminism really means
and represents and while I celebrate and
endorse this Rising wholeheartedly
I am so aware of the desperate need for
transformation to take place further
afield where girls and women cannot even
reach the lowest rung of the ladder in
terms of gender rights and empowerment
this is why I endorse and identify the
term global feminism which is inclusive
of all women and men and boys everywhere
and I believe that men and boys must be
included because they need to be part of
the change too
[Applause]
was that enthusiastic Oh what kind of
half half the next I'm gonna make you
really enthusiastic you see if men and
boys from my perspective are excluded
from the dialogue we're still left with
the same old misogyny abuse and lack of
equality right do you not agree okay are
there any men in the room like it's just
women what the heck I'm seeing welcome
you are welcome I'm saying this to you
because I truly endorse a man who truly
embraces the term feminist who can who
can take this terminology into his heart
and mind teach his sons and daughters
what that means respect equality equal
opportunity and from my perspective we
must welcome all men all men of everyone
every color every race from every place
all of us together not separately anyway
that's where my passion lies so as
communicators you are communicators
aren't you and influencers you all
appreciate the value and importance of
terminology I'm asking you to help me
put this term out there in the zeitgeist
because if you don't have the
terminology you don't have the way to
address anything and I think this term
is simple and I think it's inclusive and
I think it's an honorable term and I
think it can help us all to move
forwards so I started a social media
campaign it's called hashtag one reason
why I'm a global feminist and for a
Luddite that's a very good place to
begin
Miami Luddite by the way because I'm
terribly ancient and very unskilled in
technologies but I'm trying I want
everyone to be able to connect the facts
about global women's rights
here and around the world here and
around the world it's very good place to
begin would you consider having your
picture taken a selfie holding a fact
with the hashtag on the top here's a
fact this is the simple fact one in
three women and girls are impacted by
physical or sexual violence in their
lifetime did you know that did you know
it's horrible I'm passing it out to you
please take one and have your photograph
taken professionally or an anomaly sense
holding this fact so you know it's like
wake up wake up this is the other fact I
said 603 million women in countries
where domestic violence is not
considered a crime don't you think
there's work to be done
come on come on pass it over so if you
go to my Instagram account you'll see
that for the last few months I've been
sitting with my facts and I feel very
lonely and I really want to start a wave
and it doesn't really matter
I'm not asking people for money I'm not
asking you to do anything particular put
a bucket of ice water over your head I
mean I wouldn't do that I wouldn't do
that
I'm just asking people if they will you
know sign up for this just to get it out
in the zeitgeist the facts not the
[ __ ] not though or whatever whatever
let's use the worm global feminists so
we can boldly go through and say we're
feminists and we're proud of it and
maybe in the future we could start to
see the changes the changes are
happening but they need to be followed
through you know activists so I someone
asked me about what does it like being
out of it I said yeah you're very
impatient you're very impatient but you
have to be so patient at the same time
you know they say that the change is
coming in
really slow way we have to stop this
glacially slow come on wake up it's time
it's so tiny it's so time to educate
it's so time to join up and join
together and stop this polarization I'm
so distressed by the polarization we all
belong in this world together no matter
what is happening in leadership we
belong together so I am going to play
you a song
well actually I'm going to play you two
songs and I don't want to give the game
away but um it's really touching for me
because I actually was very very
fortunate to have recorded and performed
with the Queen of Soul the real Queen of
Soul Aretha Franklin and I just wanted
to mention the Risa today because she
came very much into my mind that as we
recorded sisters are doing it for
themselves back in 1980 we Laura Aretha
had lived in the vocal booth and she
said something that really made me smile
she said equal pay that's what we say
and and I said she gets she gets the
message she knows what this is about
equal opportunity equal you know gender
rights so she said the song is in all
9th and I'm not gonna play it right away
I'll play something else to make you sad
first and then I'll make you happy so
bear with me while I managed to gonna
get up the stairs I'm an elderly person
now I get I need handsome young feminist
men to help me